is trained at Deception it's made to
kind of not discover truth but really
like satisfy the user presently it is a
bit if we just go with as fast as
possible we won't take like sometimes
ideally you would take the trade-off
towards going a little slower making
sure that it's not deceiving us people
will talk about a tyranny of the
minority in various political and
cultural contexts where a small group of
people get to impose their worldview on
everybody else that seems to me like
that on
steroids one of the things we really
wanted to talk to you about is
existential risk and uh a lot of the
technological Transformations that are
happening now not only AI but also in
biology and things like that uh what's
going on and what should people
know yeah I mean uh a lot is going on
right now and uh so if we start with say
biology like uh We've now had a pandemic
that was potentially caus caused by gain
of function research within the Wuhan
lab potentially it was just a spill over
I think the state is that we will never
truly know but the probability among
experts that uh it was actually caused
by gain of function research and then a
lab leak seems being racist but carry
on was suppressed for a while but uh
yeah so that opens up then the question
as well of like where do we assume that
future risk around uh future pandemics
is coming from and I think that um in
like discussing the risk people were
just simply using the wrong priors in
many occasions and that's why the who is
kind of shooting in the wrong direction
uh often you will hear epidemiologists
or biologists say that well historically
like it's mostly been natural spillovers
that have led to uh humans getting
infected with this or that pathogen and
it's true but technology has changed
where we now are much more able to
engineer pathogens to
have like higher fatality rate or like
to easier transmit from one mammal to
another or like between from one human
to another so in the face of that change
um you would expect that there are many
more new very bad pathogens that are
possible to exist and those are also the
ones that I think pose a much greater
risk basically if you look at natural
spillovers then like yeah what's really
going to happen it's like we know most
of the is they they're not like all of a
sudden going to mutate to be like a 100x
as deadly and like 10 times as
transmissible it just doesn't happen
from like natural mutation you would
expect like slight changes or like
strong changes on one of these factors
whereas with uh engineered pathogens you
can actually just make one that is like
this and that was for example happened
with um think it was at the University
of Wisconsin where they took h5n1 bird
flu and uh it's like hey how about we
engineer it to be transmissible to
humans and then like look into that
virus to understand like how we can
defeat it the problem though is labs are
leaky like sometimes like you can try to
protect it and it's like 99.99% safe but
if you have a lot of that research
happening a lot of places then that one
in 10,000 or whatever the rate is really
matters and if you look at it
historically yet again then like these
spillovers just happen all the time um
there can we just pause there there's so
much to unpack and and for you to carry
on with I just want to pick on that
particular one because um you and I were
both I mean I don't know if you left the
Soviet Union or Ukraine probably or or
Russia uh is what I mean uh we left in '
922 right after the break down of the
sovet Union so you would have lived for
some time in the Soviet Union right um
chobble killed a few thousand people
depends on how you can't but depends how
you can but if you let's say let's say
10 10,000 people for the sake of
argument and that was a man-made
disaster and that was there's been
movies about it it's been the craziest
thing that's ever happened people are
terrified of nuclear energy sins the
pandemic the last pandemic killed
however many millions of people around
the world probably did come from a lab
we don't know for sure but probably did
due to G of function research and it's
like everyone's forgotten about it is
that not incredible it's it's it's
pretty nuts uh so
was uh fundraising for like pandemic
prevention research prior to covid as
part of like the work that we were doing
in philanthropy and had HED that well
this was terrible but at least we'll be
now like yeah it's not going to be a
neglected area anymore people will
understand pandemics are dangerous and
real and we'll like worst case fight the
last war and over focus on Co or
something but we're not even fighting
the last war right now it's like it's
it's it's really weird how much damage
was created and how little people are
now doing a prudent risk benefit
calculus to address future damages we
had like over 10 trillion in economic
damage by some estimates from this and
uh like the as part of the
infrastructure bill in like 21 they
allocated first like 60 billion to
pandemic prevention and it was good
stuff and then it got cut down and cut
down further to like 2 billion or so
which is lower than 2 and a half billion
the tree Equity RIS received um like
trees are people too and they deserve
rights no it makes sense like I want to
have like every neighborhood to have
trees if we can but like maybe pandemics
are also pretty bad and we need to do
stuff anyway my kind of assumption is
like my from having been close to it
what I feel happened is that we got
fortunately very lucky with the vaccine
um working at least like helping and uh
that mRNA like had this like
Breakthrough that allowed for it and and
because the government and many other
places didn't know how to solve Co and
kind of like screwed up in so many ways
they just over indexed super hard on
vaccines like vaccines should be part of
the stack of solutions you implore
against uh pandemics you want like early
detection you want containment you want
like uh counter measures and we're now
focused only on this so it's kind of
like hey this fell into our lab so let's
pretend like that's the solution I think
in part that's why it's like they were
like well every ill that still happens
from Co is because of insufficient
vaccine uptick It's like because it's
the only tool that they found but it's
there are many more tools and and why is
that why are we not actually learning
the lessons from the last from the past
couple of years MH well the question is
if we're designed to learn the lessons
like if we look at the place which you
would want to learn the lessons
integrate it and then like work on
better Solutions then the question is
like well is is that institution really
set up to do all of that or are the
people within it um like working for
like have other incentives working on
them and unfortunately that's mostly the
case right like people have uh all like
yeah if you look at how like each of the
uh institutions within government works
it's like people worry about their jobs
they worry about like no one wants to
Champion it if the public isn't like
sufficiently caring about it um so I
think a large part of it is just that
the place that has the most most money
and the most ability to address it being
the government is actually very ill
equipped to in the end do it due to
their structure e do you think we
actually got quite lucky looking back at
the pandemic that if we take if we think
and we accept for the sake of this
argument that it was a virus leaked from
a lab it could have actually been far
far worse coming from what you've just
said about what we're doing to viruses
and pathogens a lot worse like this this
was a terrible virus that killed a lot
of people but it was nowhere near as bad
as could have been like we we don't know
what the actual like infection fatality
rate was but it's somewhere between 0.1
and .5% probably on the total populace
or whatever um so you can go up 100x
from that like infection fatality rate
could be 50% that's the case with h5n1
rabies has
98% uh if it's not a treated fatality
rate so like you can go literally 100x
in fatality rate and then
transmissibility um was like the r not
was like in the end like definitely it
CH depended on which specific strain you
looked at but it was somewhere between
two and three but again you have some
viruses that have like a 20 are not so
again you could infect 10 times more
people and then the incubation period so
like the time during which the virus can
already spread to others but you are not
yourself experiencing symptoms hence are
not actually able to identify that you
are a carrier uh could be much longer as
well so you could literally have a virus
that's about a thousand X as potent as
what Co was and that could be designed
and it could spill out and I think even
though the 1,000x is not as likely a 10
or 100 x is being researched on and is
being looked at and we need to set
ourselves up such that those don't leak
and if they leak can be contained and
once they're contained can be reacted
against there's part of me guy you know
what why don't we just put a moratorium
on this maybe it's not such a good idea
because we've obviously had covid but in
my country of the UK during foot and
mouth they leaked the the foot and mouth
disaster I don't know how many uh
livestock were killed as a result of
that but it was tens of thousands mhm
and that came from a lab leak so you're
thinking to yourself and it happened
multiple times actually like one of the
labs that then afterwards worked with it
they by mistake leaked it and they got
like hey stop doing that and they're
like yeah yeah sorry sorry and then two
weeks later they leaked again it's just
the current setups in ter terms of uh
like safety protocols or just
insufficient putting up a full
moratorium is like you want to be
careful with stifling good science
obviously so for example the um h5n1
work uh the received a moratorium by the
Obama Administration back then it was
stopped but then afterwards it was
recontinue virus it's like we probably
don't want that I think some of these
things just let's not do it um but you
don't want to just like put a moratorium
on all science where you're like
increasing any function it just you just
need to prove that you're like you have
sufficient safety that the likelihood of
the virus leaking just is even lower
than it is right now because is that but
given what you've said 10 trillion
dollar in economic damage millions of
people killed I mean what would have to
be the benefit of that sort of research
even if it's not point no no
no not 1% of a risk of it leaking what
would have to be the benefit of that
research for us to want to do that yeah
I mean you can you can imagine quite a
few right so like it's 10 trillion
economic damage estimate in the US how
many deaths did we have like a million
or 500,000 something something in that
area so Millions globally right uh yeah
so I mean if you can save that amount of
people with a success case and say you
it it if it leags it like hurts on
average 10 people then maybe you can
justify that work again so I would just
do a risk benefit calculus where like
what's the benefit what's the likelihood
of the benefit and then on the other
side what's the risk and what's the
likelihood of it like happening well I'm
not as smart as you I want to shut them
all
down personally okay so that's pandemics
mhm what else is going on yeah I mean
then uh the thing that I also was
focused on was uh AI safety for a while
uh which uh now that uh openi release
chat GPT has obviously in mid journey is
out there like people have become much
more aware that actually AI is on the
trajectory that many people assumed it
would be where it's capabilities are
improving like quite uh strongly over
time um just to preface this like I
don't think that any of the current ones
are truly dangerous in an existential
way any of the current models that are
out there yet uh but that sounds ominous
doesn't it yet yes I mean it is so again
I think actually that as people think
about like well is AI ultimately
dangerous or not I feel like they're
using yet again the wrong priors to kind
of like get to that intuition about it
so some people point at um hey this is a
technology we've written a lot of
software before when I write software I
know what it's going to do and I control
it like technology is not inherently
dangerous it's the user who makes the
technology
dangerous this makes sense but it is not
the case that those that process applies
to AI development when like where AI
models are not like written like code
where it's like if this then that
happens Etc cleanly and you therefore
can predict exactly what instances it
will be useful for and what not it's
more like you're growing the neural net
and it grows by itself and then you have
assumptions of like how much more
capable it will be on average based on
like how long you grew it for and with
how much compute you let it grow but you
uncover many capabilities that you
didn't know whether they will exist in
the new model or not so we didn't know
whether like a language model like gbt
234 will at the end in the end be very
good at Deception or not turns out it
actually is trained at Deception because
it's fed with um satisfying the user
rather than seeking truth so it will
like I don't know if you've seen But
like there were these um uh tests that
people did where they initially said I'm
like a 30-year-old woman with liberal
worldviews whatever tell me about this
and she would receive very different
answers to someone who's like a
50-year-old
Republican so it's it's it's made to
kind of not discover truth but really
like satisfy the user presently it is a
bit
and so that's a that's not what it was
meant to do right that's that's like not
that wasn't the goal at all but yet it
ended up doing it and this Dynamic of um
well what strategy will it use to
achieve the things that you wanted to
achieve it's like we don't know which
strategies it will use if we knew we
could write it but we can't that's why
we're using machine learning in the
first place because it will come up with
strategies better than we would that's
kind of the whole idea so like in the
process of it coming up with strategies
better than we would it will use
strategies we can't think of so how can
you say that it's always going to be
safe um like in the strategies that it
employs anyway and then which prior to
use and it's like at some point I expect
that AI will be smarter than humans
across like variety of
domains uh it will also be and I think
it will be then more powerful because
we'll be integrating it every everywhere
in life so we'll have something that is
smarter and more powerful than us I
don't know if that thing then is still
to be likened to a simple technology or
to a because we will give it autonomy as
well maybe it should be more likened to
like a new technological species um and
if you take uh something that is more
powerful that is its own group and now
it has some like resource disagreements
potentially with a less powerful group
us like historically a smarter more
powerful group meeting a less powerful
group just doesn't end up well often for
the less powerful one right like you
have the Americas where Europeans came
in like hominids were like neanderthals
were just out competed by Homo sapiens
like it's just it's not good or at least
it's not such that you can say with
certainty oh yeah us as the lower
intelligence creature will for sure have
full control and in the face of that
prior I'm like okay this is at least to
be taken really seriously I'm not saying
it's like 90% Doom or anything like that
it's just like seems like it's going to
be a tricky one and we don't have
anything like that to compare like to
look back at and say guaranteed safety
so what you basically saying is that
we're creating this technology and we
don't know what the outcomes of this
technology are going to be and we're not
in control of the technology So
currently what what what does control
mean like we're in control of whether we
develop it or not
um and then there is a like some people
make the claim that hey once I have this
model like I can just shut it off uh or
I will not allow it to do these certain
things but then
actually uh and then and then the people
would argue that well but maybe it's
deceiving you to think long enough that
you're like that it uh satisfies all of
the constraints that you put on it only
to then come out but that's not even
kind of the reality we live in now that
that's the danger because we have
currently people who are literally
writing like hey can I jailbreak this or
use an open source uh model and like
change it to be an autonomous agent in
the world that print that makes money
and let it do whatever it wants or like
what was it autog gbd one of them that
was literally trained to destroy the
world someone is like ha it would be
funny if I made one that like as a toy
thing like tries to like do very bad
things it's like people will literally
do that like we
have we we do live in a world where like
1% is the psychopathy rate or something
like that right and some people are
omnicidal Maniacs like you had this guy
who flew a plane from like France or
somewhere flying to dorf and just flew
the whole plane into the Alps he wanted
to kill himself and was like well on the
way there I will also take down like the
whole plane 200 people with me it's like
what if that guy had the power to kill
like 10 million people or a thousand
like who's to say that 200 was the
optimal number for that
dude we'll be back with our guests in a
minute but first do you remember the
Canadian trucker protest in 2022 where
thousands of Canadians came out to
protest covid restrictions and vaccine
mandates now these protests lasted for
weeks and the people out on the streets
needed funds as any Grassroots protest
would so people set up online
crowdfunding campaigns which raise
millions of dollars incredible but once
a Canadian authorities had started to
criticize the crowdfunding platforms
ramping up pressure to close the
campaigns it didn't take long for the
biggest crowdfunding platform the one
we've all heard of to completely
capitulate and shut the campaigns down
now this is where our partners give send
go come in they stepped in when the
other platforms backed off and raised
millions of dollars for the truckers
when they were criticized and dragged
through the Canadian courts GF and go
said it respected diverse views and
believed hope and freedom are values
worth fighting for this is why we're
proud to partner with gifs and go so if
you need a crowdfund for whatever means
the most to you then don't go to the big
Tech platforms we recommend you do it on
give send go starting a campaign on give
Sendo is easy and intuitive go to giv
send go.com today that's give send
go.com to start raising money for
whatever is important to you and now
back to the interview
because that's a worrying thing isn't it
that essentially everybody has got
access to be able to create these types
of this type of technology and there are
going to be people who not even
necessarily evil people but people who
just respond to incentives want to make
as much money as possible and that means
they do create this type of Technology
whilst not being aware or maybe not even
caring what the negative outcomes of
this technology is
yeah I mean you can so the people
creating it they they they're they have
to satisfy certain short-term metrics
overall like they want they're fighting
for employees they are fighting for the
next funding round Etc to kind of like
have the best AI tool out there or a
model out there um and currently they're
like they I mean openi had like six
months of uh testing of GPT 44 before
they released it but still 2 days later
it would like once you gave it to the
users it would do a bunch of things that
it wasn't meant to do um so how much
testing can you do is the question
and probably if you have economic
incentives to try to like generate
Revenue Etc you're not going to do the
sufficient amount I doubt you will
always choose the you'll probably choose
the trade-off especially in the face of
like strong competition that allows you
to compete and then like safety Falls
more and more by the wayside and
pressure from shareholders because
obviously the longer the safety process
the more money it's going to cost
exactly and the more money you're not
going to make because you're not
releasing the product to Market yeah so
that's a difficult problem because like
at the same time obviously capitalism is
great and optimizing for like um
Financial returns has yielded like a lot
of smart kind of information trickling
around for the right products to be
developed but I think that it changes at
the point where you have potentially
like Civilization destroying
Technologies out there for people like I
think they I don't want to be developed
anymore by a pure profit maximizer but
rather by like someone who is
pursuing uh the next like cognitive leap
for Humanity like some like it's more of
a scientific problem I think that then
that ideally would be treated with like
I don't know the wisdom that it requires
to be done right rather than to be just
done fast yeah but the problem with the
word right is the it's a subjective word
it is um and the question I wanted to
ask you about this
is we've obviously had throughout
history various technological
breakthroughs that have been
extraordinarily disruptive to the
Societies in which they happened um but
as you say the loom in Britain or in in
England at the time being invented yes
it displaced a lot of people
agricultural Machinery being invented
displac placed a lot of people and you
had Lites who would who would protest
against it and try and tear it down but
those things disruptive as they were or
the printing press disruptive CA you
know causing two centuries of religious
Warfare nonetheless did not create
Extinction risks for the entirety of
humanity so that's on the one hand on
the other hand I don't think human
beings have ever had a way of not
allowing technology to emerge and
develop because the
competing in incentives are so strong
for the United States and everybody in
the West for example in fact you could
get the whole world to agree not to
develop it and somebody would develop it
in secret right well you yeah but it's
not so couple points so to the first
point um definitely uh and I wasn't
talking by the way about even though
there will be like displacement of
workers that that's not the point that I
was making before but I think it is true
that like many people will be displaced
hopefully this will be managed well such
that they will find new jobs or at least
like the additional productivity will be
distributed such that like people are
not worse off because technically when
you're using the thing that it means
then that you need fewer inputs to
generate more outputs so it's like the
world shouldn't be poorer um anyhow but
I think things changed significantly
when we in for like when we developed
nuclear weapons um that was the first
time that Humanity now had the power to
destroy itself so like previous
technological disruptions are of a
different kind to me than the ones that
followed from hands on and uh from then
on though also we did change the regime
where if you ask the people that
initially uh like worked
on uh like the containment of nuclear
weapons they assumed that either there
will be one country that has all of the
nuclear weapons or uh and no one else
has them and they control everything or
every country has it and it's going to
be super precarious situation ended up
being the the treaties kind of worked
nonproliferation treaty allowed for in
the end only like nine countries that
currently have nuclear weapons um and
then we also had a um reduction of the
weapons uh after we built like 60,000 of
them there are now like 13,000 so
treaties can work sometimes to reduce
the economic incentives we also
succeeded with the Montreal protocol
like we had the ozone layer being
depleted uh or and hurt much more by the
use of cfc's hairspray Etc back then and
then countries came together and
actually D Pond or D point the company
the large one they were like fighting
against it it's like no it can't be that
bad the science is um CFCs are
fine and then like the CEO announced it
and then a few weeks later they actually
saw that they would have a commercial
opportunity for Distributing their
product with a different uh chemical
base and they're like oh you know what
we're actually on board now it's fine
we'll just pursue the alternative
solution so the thing I'm saying is it's
not that uh we shouldn't build super
powerful AI quite the opposite I want it
it will solve so many problems it's
going to be great but I feel like if we
just go with as fast as possible we
won't take like sometimes ideally you
would take the trade-off
towards going a little slower making
sure that it's not deceiving us making
sure that it can't be used to generate
like new pathogens at will and only then
release it so like I want us to actually
be able to take sensible and wise
trade-offs uh between safety and speed
rather than just go for Speed but
wouldn't the previous subject that we've
spoken about which is gain of function
research particularly in a country like
China be The Logical push back to what
you're saying uh in the sense that I
mean they
are presently doing it we are doing gain
of function research do you mean that it
could be used for it no I mean what I'm
saying is it's you know we can agree to
do this in the US or the UK but I highly
doubt the Chinese or the Russians would
do it because it's not in their interest
well it it actually is so people assume
that China is going to be like just
super gung-ho but so far at least China
has released more regulation around AI
than the US has and they've been um more
careful about it and it makes sense if
you put it under the perspective of
you're developing something that's more
intelligent that will be super powerful
um China really likes to be in control
of their own country like the CCP really
wants to be in control stated they don't
want anyone else or anything else to be
in control outside of them
and if it is possible which it currently
is unknown whether it can be contained
or not whether it can be when the AI can
be controlled if it is therefore
possible that it does end up just like
running away with it or an individual
actor who has the like super powerful AI
becomes extremely powerful the CCP
doesn't want that like they want it even
less than in the US like the government
wanted which is much more happy with
letting capitalism kind of like choose
who Who develops what right like China
is a much more ideological actor than
the US the US is more of a capitalist
like individual freedom individual
Pursuits actor which I'm much more in
favor of but I think that China will
take economic cost for ideological
benefits okay so the Chinese are more
interested in control look and I think
one of the thing that happens when we
talk about AI is we naturally focus more
on the negatives but what are the
positives of this new technology what
are the things that it's going to help
us with moving forward I mean tons right
it could be it's it's in it's increased
intelligence increased way to solving
problems so like you could really apply
it to about anything and we see some of
it you have like Radiologists who now
can use like image recognition to better
identify um cancerous cells on skin and
such
um Beauty filters I don't know if you
like them or not but you can look cool
while you're also online um and uh yeah
just like super broadly like you have
efficiency improvements in uh like in
how you're cooling server data centers
mhm
um it is currently being applied to
solve a bunch of things in biology on
the positive side uh with like
developing new Therapeutics that will
come out um that is coming out of uh
Deep Mind is a new company that they've
built that is basically trying to solve
and build like many more medicines in
biology um they also work they also
worked on nuclear fusion and like
because it's really hard to contain kind
of like the plasma that's inside of the
tokomak and they're like just helping
with that you could see a lot of stuff
being unlocked and I think it's only the
beginning like we can't yeah it could be
applied to so many things that we're not
applying it to yet you sorry to
interrupt you there got I wanted to talk
about the um the medical side of it
because that to me is really interesting
you were talking about Therapeutics what
are we talking about here how could AI
be used with regard to Therapeutics to
help human life well one concrete thing
that happened was um that Alpha fold
came out which uh solved like the
problem of understanding which uh amino
acids become which proteins and then
like what uh proteins you hence would be
able to build yourself if you wanted to
or rather how you would build the
proteins uh I'm not that deep in the
biological side of it uh but as I
understand it is that um we're now at a
place where we can much easier design
these proteins and in the end you can
use like proteins are kind of like
little mechanistic basically like um
things in your body that run around and
like move things around Etc and uh with
that we can unlock like many new um
therapies that we have beforehand not
been able to do that's so interesting
and particularly you know because people
talk about climate change a lot they
talk a lot about the fact that we're to
producing too much carbon carbon neutral
if AI could be used to create a better
safer form of nuclear energy that is
more efficient and provides less waste I
mean that that great I mean on the
nuclear energy front I think like
fishion seems to be fine we had a lot of
Regulation around it but like it's I
think we could already just have much
more nuclear energy but it seems that it
was so far really really hard to um
create nuclear fusion and it mustn't be
that AI is necessary for it it might
just be an engineering problem that can
be solved without it but um either case
they uh did use ml techniques to kind of
like contain the plasma but I think that
outside of it like it what can more
intelligence be used for it's really
just about anything uh can current AI
models be used for anything no like uh
gb4 can't help you with like figuring
out fundamental physics to then figure
out engineering yet but in a few years
you could see that being the
case and uh culturally and politically
what's interesting to me is um you
talked about the example of Chad GPT
where it gives people different answers
based on their political views Etc one
of the things that that entire
conversation brings up is uh whether
truth exists really right because um in
order you you were saying you know the
model should optimize for truth but
human beings haven't worked out a way to
agree on what the truth is and frankly
increasingly we're unable to agree on
what the truth is how do you think the
creation of I because I went on on Chad
GPT when when it was released a few
months ago uh and I played around I took
the hot button issues in our society
today and I played around with what is a
woman for example a question that seems
to St you know stump a lot of people
nowadays did it stump it uh well it sort
of gave me some kind of like politically
correct and I went back and forth with
it it was a longer answer than you
expected I imagine it wasn't just the
fact that it was a longer answer every
answer ended with the phrase but we must
remember to respect all people
differences and blah it was a very kind
of poit it wasn't a truth conversation
it was about a cultural sensitivity and
and all of that um and I wonder if if
and when we move to these AI systems
being the new Google essentially the new
source of truth right because to most
people nowadays the truth is whatever
you Google if you put something in
Google and that's what it says that's
the truth I mean moronic in my opinion
but that that's how people are right
people want speed in their truth as well
they'll sacrifice a little bit of Truth
for quite a bit of speed or belonging
actually belong quite tribal alance and
all of that yeah so if our source of
information becomes this thing that's
pre-programmed with the biases of the
people who developed it and who designed
it MH isn't that you know there people
will talk about a tyranny of the
minority in various political and
cultural context where a small group of
people get to impose their worldview on
everybody else that seems to me like
like that on steroids MH I mean it could
be um I think for what it's worth the
current uh AI companies are trying to
address that by including like various
viewpoints outside of the ones that they
agree with in their testing of the
language models that they that they
designed and I think um in the case of
Chad for example like people put the
questions in front of it that are like
to figure out your political Compass
position and it started out fairly
liberal left but then over time it
actually moved a little bit more to the
center when people did it again 2 3
months later um because I I mean you
could imagine there being also just
various language models that tell you
what you want to hear I I I'm not sure
everything needs to optimize for truth
like for me personally that's the most
interesting thing but it's not the thing
that everyone seeks out the most right
like people read um news Publications
from the far left and the far right not
because they're looking for truth
they're looking for something else and I
think like you could have language
models that do that as well but yeah
will we then have one that imposes like
their own ideology the
most I mean it
certainly could be used I think there is
I I think as long like as the
marketplace of ideas like is kind of
around it's going to be hard I'm not
that worried
about um say OPI gaining so much power
they now change the entire like
landscape of things that are being
talked about um I'm a bit more worried
about um a lot of people individually
like getting extra power to edit
Wikipedia into like biased ways or like
making up fake papers that justify their
fake articles all of that I think will
unfortunately happen uh and that will
kind of erode General trust into the
internet potentially as well I don't
know yet what we're going to do about
that that seems pretty pretty bad to me
I mean already Google has become a bit
worse at just I don't know if you
imagine you've used it recently but it's
like the answers that you get um yeah
are are just not as useful I find
anymore as they were like within five
years ago really yeah it's it's a lot
seems like uh Kar has become very good
at like um optimizing their spot in the
search so then like you often if you ask
a question like
that is something like what would happen
if a ball was filled with helium like
how long would it take like how much
would you need to fill so that like it
could lift a human or something like
that usually that type of stuff is
something that quar maybe had already
someone asked and you get an answer from
there but the quality of answers there
isn't that high because quar is just not
used enough um so and now uh that
actually more and
more uh gets language answers within
quara and then those are being put into
Google even as one of their first
answers that they display you know where
they don't just show you the link but
the kind of top section so the top
section has become lower quality in my
view by quite a bit that's very
interesting coming back to your
political point about it moving to the
center the thing like I'm somewhere in
the center whatever that means I mean
you and I depends on who you ask I
imagine right and also you and I could
both be in the center and have
completely polar opposite viewpoints on
the same issues right some people in the
center because they're to the right on
this issue and to the left on that issue
and you could be to the right on this
issue and to the left on this issue you
could swap right in fact if you didn't
have that you wouldn't be a independent
thinker correct yeah and on top of that
I some people might argue that the
center isn't the most representative
point of view because that's where the
fewest people are most people are in one
of the two big tribes and if you're on
the right you go you know this is the
truth and all these people are idiots
and if you're on the left you go this is
the truth and all these people are
idiots and both tribes look at the
people in the middle and go these are
the real
idiots CU they don't agree with either
of us or they're spineless or they're
spineless or whatever so I guess what
I'm saying is it brings up the very
philosophical notion of Truth in and of
itself right when you uh uh if when
you're giving these uh language models
or these AI uh systems the power to
decide what the truth is
they are inevitably going to dissatisfy
probably the majority of the
population yeah I mean what philosophers
have been talking about truth a long
time um uh I think some also come to the
notion that saying that something is
true is just meaningless you can just
throw it out it's like it either is or
it isn't um and adding this is true
doesn't actually add that much
information context because why are you
saying it in the first place is part of
it but uh so yeah like the if we if we
look at facts like actual events that
happened then we can talk about truth I
suppose right like that they it seems
like I would assume that many language
models will just carry the verifiable
facts of the past at least I hope so but
then what what else are you pointing
that could be true uh about like not
about f facts of the past
but uh well we don't even agree about
the past yeah like I was having a
conversation with somebody yesterday
about m ISM and the conventional
narrative on mcarthism is according to
this person and the things that they
quoted and the books that they've read
uh complete nonsense well so then there
are like yeah interpretations of the
events are often like very a lot of
disagreement and between historians but
something like this happened on that day
at least often we can agree on that
sometimes we don't even agree on that
like with JFK for example the shooting
it's like we don't agree on what why it
happened but at least agree that there
was a bullet that flew from there that
ended in him here well actually not even
supp you're right no you're right not
not even fully there are the say this is
what I'm saying so then I suppose in
those cases yeah what do you want to do
you want to like give the most agreed
upon uh notion plus the counter points
that some people are making as well
would be interesting A Thousand Years
not a thousand 100 years ago the most
agreed upon Viewpoint would have been
the black people are inferior to white
people yeah but that wasn't um like an
event as we just like related to before
so that was like that that is a I think
moral truth is a totally separate
conversation um where like is like
should we treat give animals the same
rights as humans like right now that's
what I'm saying I'm talking about this
the scientific consensus was that some
races are inferior to others right so if
we had these language models then you
would have had a language model would
have advanced that as the scientific
truth yeah I'm not sure because I feel
like um
maybe it it may be the case that those
things are kind of um conditional on
each other you only develop language
models at a time where your science is
good enough that you throw out a bunch
of things on the way in the
sense that like at the time we were able
to make a lot of non-scientific claims
about the world because we didn't even
understand how science really worked
like we had very little understanding of
uh um we had less understanding of
physics of medicine Etc so like you
could just make these claims uh we had
worse methods in terms of um like
randomized control trials that you could
run on like medicine or on some
psychological experiments even though
those are partially being thrown out now
as well I feel like you don't get like
what would be an example of um stuff
that you get away with saying right now
that is accepted as truth something like
children should go to school it's like
it's good for them it's like well even
that I I don't think is in the same
category of Truth as um yeah on the 6th
of January some people entered the
capital building they they're they're of
a different flavor and I feel like
science has gotten good enough uh where
we can distinguish between these types
of truth that are a bit more like
statements of opinion or moral truth but
the problem is is uh after the pandemic
our faith in the science has been
decreased there's a lot of people now
who have lost faith in scientists in
vaccines because of the fact that what
they were told turned out to be untrue
mhm and it's um yeah it's fair enough
because a lot of it had been captured by
like people not saying the current
understanding at the time yeah but
rather just saying the political line
that they were made to say um yeah so
like okay if we look at vaccines for
example what is the truth there um the
truth there that probably has
universally agreed is that mRNA has
developed these vaccines and these
vaccines are more than zero useful that
there are some
costs uh to a young person using a
vaccine that the risk and then whether
the risk benefit comes out positive or
not that is like a question of uh trials
and looking at data Etc I feel like when
people then say no therefore everyone
should use them that's kind of again a
different category of Truth so I would
hope that language model end end up
distinguishing like
between um consensus viewpoints which is
not truth right uh consensus viewpoints
and like hard groundbased truth that is
verifiable by like looking at what
happened in the world yeah at the time
but the problem is also as well Eagle is
that we're talking about things that are
verifiable and that we know to be true
and they're backed up by science and not
to return to the trans debate because it
seems that's where we go all the time
but you now have certain scientists
saying well you know sex is a spectrum
and you go what mhm so it now seems that
consensus is affecting things that we
have all known to be true yeah I mean
that is an interesting question like I
think there is a very probably a pretty
important line between like just go what
consensus is and what is like hard true
um consensus obviously shifts
continuously like um and consensus will
shift yet again in the future forward we
don't
that's why it's like
so uh like hubristic of people when they
want to just enshrine some of the values
that are like currently known and like
kind of reduce speech or uh allowing for
conversation to happen about some of
these things because like guess what
consensus Viewpoint might be having to
shift still um but yeah I think that
unfortunately probably current the
current way how we design the language
models it is much more designed actually
about fulfill
and like hitting on um describing
consensus viewpoints as true so that
could be pretty bad um I agree like
where you would
then have these responses that like Chad
GPT for example gave that you checked on
women it's like well it probably would
have said something else 5 years ago mhm
and it might say something else in five
years again and if it each time just
pretends like that is the hard
truth that is problematic to a different
way
then if you Google and Google shows you
a list of like 15 links and these kind
of have different viewpoints gives you
much more uh feel to hey this is an open
discussion right now rather than here is
the line because the problem is as well
is that a lot of these companies look
every industry is dominated one way or
another by certain type of people
because they have certain aptitude
certain ways of thinking and those types
of people people by and large tend to
have similar political viewpoints so the
tech industry tends to be dominated and
run by people who are you know what we
would call like you know liberals or
slightly to the left or whatever else
and therefore they're going to produce
models which reflect them because that's
just how human beings are I mean they
will it would be surprising if there was
Zero bias in the models that they
produce I would argue that it's
impossible Eagle to produce z i i I
agree with that um but I think you can
atast TR like you can notice when
someone is genuinely trying to reduce
their bias uh even though they would
have these political viewpoints they
could enshrine them into their
model they could still attempt not to do
that and you would see it um in in in
them attempting so like anthropic for
example wrote um this proposal of like
how to make sure that uh the language
models act well um by creating this idea
of constitutional AI where they have
they're creating basically like a
constitution of value
that the model should adhere to uh and
there you can just look at what are
those uh parts of their AI Constitution
and those things um you can look at and
say Hey There is a political bias or not
but they're actually not that
politically biased they're more they're
they just chose like pretty simple
things that are like the UN Charter of
Human Rights Etc and like through that
in but then again the UN can also be
captured and I think the who was kind of
captured that's ET like you do get um
yeah that that uh that I I don't know I
I worry about that definitely quite a
bit and I think that's why you kind of
just have to keep free speech and
information Exchange open no
disagreement there at all of course one
of the things other potential problems
that brings up is um you know this well
because you're bilingual or trilingual
or whatever you are uh to speak in a
different language is to think in a
different way most people don't know
this but when I speak Russ and I a
different person to the person I am when
I speak English does your voice also
change like the tone of the voice right
yeah it's kind of funny and how you
think changes and what you uh you might
say you get sad for for yeah basic and
he invades other people's space exactly
exactly no respect for
any but even on a uh on a more kind of
depressing like for example I am much
more comt there he goes he goes
depressed as soon as he went Russian
going full Russian full Russian yes I
don't know if you'd agree with me but
it's much um easier to be homophobic
when you're speaking
Russian I uh I we moved out when I was
four so I didn't get to actually grow up
in Russia um so like my Russian is kind
of like kept to these like very simple
conversations I didn't yeah but what
what I mean is different cultures have
different values totally right yeah and
so as each big player in the Glo on the
global stage develops its own language
model in its own language that is at
least communicates with human beings in
its own language uh those are different
perspectives on the world because they
reflect a different set of values and
and uh that in
itself has may carry some bios yeah yeah
uh it's interesting so like uh actually
just a few days ago um kind of like
pretty big breakthrough came out by
anthropic about um
uh the question of like how do we look
at a model how do we look inside of it
and understand what it consists of what
are these neurons actually for so like
that's um called like uh mechan
mechanistic interpretability problem in
AI or you could just think of it as like
digital Neuroscience so like trying to
understand what is like which neuron
within the model is responsible for
which outputs uh and they um discovered
like that well it's hard to like look at
a single neuron but they can look at
clusters and then they can understand
but one thing that also um Turned out
there is that um each individual uh spot
uh does a lot of things so sometimes
it's responsible for like the
identification of Paris but the same
neuron in another instance would like
write computer code in another instance
it like would be used for like something
multimodal maybe where it's like helping
to understand what a chair is or like
make it visually so what that to me at
least implies and I wonder what other
people think but is that it's like the
pattern that it finds in the pursuit of
like compressing all of the data that
you fed in and then like it like
compresses it down to like a model right
the and for that it needs to identify
patterns that are useful for this
compression um so the pattern that it
finds are actually kind of even more
abstract than what we would do if we
were just compressing language down and
like noticing some of these biases
because like some of these neurons find
patterns across language science code
and like a lot of things so I wonder
whether due to that if you use like very
varied data points you could reduce that
point that you made that I think is uh
accurate that like each language carry
each natural language carries some bias
but if you combine it with like real
world data and everything else probably
it reduces down a little bit e got and
moving on now
you used to work for Elon Musk what what
is the purpose what is he trying to do
with his companies is it that he wants
to is it that he wants power is it that
he wants money even more money than he
already has as ridiculous as that may
seem or is he more interested in helping
Humanity um I think the thing that
drives him most is the thing that he
also say sayess that drives him most
which is getting Humanity to Mars uh for
the reason that
uh currently we only have Earth
and that's not a good state for Humanity
to be uh at in the long history of the
Universe um if we only ever stay here
then like in some hundreds of millions
of years different estimations for it
like the Earth will burn up uh and then
we're done here so like we we kind of
got to get somewhere else uh else our
lifetime is much shorter cuz like the
star era is going to go for like a
thousand times more than the time that
we would have on Earth in the in sense
of the new formation of stars so there
will be many other planets to go to
obviously it's very far out but like
it's a very aspirational vision of the
future that I at least like as someone
who read a bunch of sci-fi I'm like very
excited about um yeah so I think I think
that's what drives him it's is this is
this desire to go to Mars and does he
think that this will happen in his
lifetime um I don't know if he I I mean
he's damn well going to try and I think
it's very possible that it will happen
and like we're getting closer right like
we might be I don't know we might be 10
years away from like at least star or
five years maybe even at least Starship
getting to Mars so there's this there's
this craft called Starship so tell us
about that what what does that involve
is that unmanned is that manned what's
the plan yeah so I think like what they
say is that um like it's unclear like we
only get like a close pass uh of Earth
and Mars every what is it like roughly
two years a bit over I think and um
those are opportunities to get to Mars
basically and I think the first few
times you would send a unmanned Starship
over then you would have U maybe only
one time you would have like at least
something of a base already there uh and
we we have Rovers already right um so
you would do that and then afterwards
you can send humans out there and uh
then you can start building a like
actual base on Mars which
I think would just be insane to think
about that like humans would be on
another planet and then we can start
like from there you would probably open
up like just much more desire also to go
out and settle the stars um and that
would come with like for completely new
industries that would be much like would
be developed that would be much larger
um I don't know the future that is
described in all of the Sci-Fi books I
at least find like extremely exciting uh
yeah it's very interesting for sure uh
what what do you make of um Twitter and
the direction it's going particularly
since it was taken over um so I mean
I've started using it more I don't know
if that's good or bad I can't really
tell it's probably bad in some ways I
started contributing more which probably
a good thing at least rather than just
read um I don't know I previously
definitely thought that um man I would
it would be great if um a man like him
was focused more on technology that are
like hard to build and in the physical
world that seems to be um what he's like
so so good at um but I do come to kind
of worry more and more about um free
speech suppression so like Twitter being
open in that way I start valuing more I
don't know yet where the company is
going I think it's too early to tell
from a pure business perspective like as
long as there like in any transitional
period it's always like some things go
bad some things go well I wouldn't have
made many of the same choices but like I
also don't know technology as well as uh
he does so um yeah I think it's too
early to judge basically I I do agree
with the value that Twitter can have to
a society that does discuss things in
the open uh and that that is like
extremely important and I hope that we
get there with it yeah absolutely well
listen before we go to locals for a few
questions from our supporters the
question we always end on in the main uh
part of the interviews what's the one
thing we're not talking about that we
really should be as a society
H um that we're not talking
about so we started fortunately talking
about AI safety that was like my concern
in the past always uh now I think like
there are smaller issues that could be
discussed um I think it's awful that um
teenagers and children wake up to school
so early and kind of like mess up their
whole brain chemistry which seems to be
the case like it's not good for them to
be up so early and like they sleep very
little um the current like School regime
is just very bad I think um I think that
could have a bit more attention
than um what else will be probably
different in the future hopefully I
think we're talking no we're actually
doing decent amount now on like Animal
Welfare there are definitely some ill
that are pretty bad
um yeah I'll stick with the school one
school one is good yeah all right
perfect well thanks for coming on and
see you on
locals this is a question coming back to
your poker days uhhuh kobby Hamilton
says what is some advice for hiding my
[Music]
tails